[Music]
all right so here's here's how it starts
out okay in Beverly Hills just two doors
down from uh LeBron's new property
there's this house it's a $4.3 million
mansion that currently is occupied by
squatters no way so it's almost like a
thing where you think it's just going to
be your typical oh some like homeless
people got in it and now they're just
staying their kind of deal cuz you know
like that's happened to the
neighborhoods I was in before super
common but it's completely not that and
it's super weird they're content
creators they might be bronnie bronnie
bronny James squatting over there the
[__] these guesses so um these squatters
have been throwing really crazy parties
there since October they got lots of
nice cars that come up and they just
block the roads they trash a
neighborhood there's tons of uh since
October there's been reports of like
numerous fires assaults arrests uh drugs
like and there's nothing that can really
be done about it for many many reasons
but this will be a really good uh crash
course into the whole squatter's right
situation how I'm interested to know
like the rules and like how do you like
navigate some things so listen to how
bad these guys are so uh the listing
agent for the house first discovered
there were squatters there when he went
to go show it to a prospected buyer and
all the locks were different W so that's
when he was like what the hell just
happened here and this is a giant it's a
really big mansion so usually the owner
of the house will work out like a
lockbox deal with the listing agent so
all agents get the code so that it
doesn't matter which company work for
21st century Remax whatever when you go
show the house you have the code and you
can go and open it right and then so uh
they find all the flyers for these
parties that these people are throwing
and it'll it'll show like online
ticketing where you could actually buy
tickets for like 75 bucks to like go to
these parties and on booking.com you can
even rent a bedroom for $300 a night W
well how are they finding these houses
are they just abandoned and they just
going in this this story is pretty long
so it's going to have a whole like thing
with that but for $300 a night you also
get a 1H hour massage with that uh
really weird so there's basically a good
deal two doors down like I said is
LeBron's new property that's still in
the process of being built because of
all these parties and [__] that they've
been having here they've had to have
like a 24-hour security detail stand
there to make sure that nothing happens
to his house all yeah to just that that
uh property line so that guy just stands
out there and just watches everything
that's going on and he says the streets
full of like there's condoms everywhere
there's nitrous oxide cans from like all
the whippits they're doing there's bunch
of Cups pools of vomit just like these
parties are pretty crazy now when you're
imagining who's like what these people
might look like actually
thinking the old Quest LMFO parties I
was thinking either like the new age
influencers so like the crazy ass
streamers that like to do the shock
content like you know like those type of
like uh like nek boys type type people
want to do crazy [__] Dy type like kick
streamer type people yeah plus if
they're able to pay 75 bucks to go to a
party that's pretty expensive for a
party yeah yeah I thought I was teenager
so influencer yeah you would think right
but uh so when police tried to get them
out the squaders were actually able to
produce driver's licenses that had the
address on them so that means they
there's a window and someone like squats
in your property if they're able to
renew their license and get that license
sent to the address and they can get it
from the mail then you've just missed
the window to kick them out without a
court eviction whoa wow so there's a
like you have to catch them before they
are able to do that that law is so
[__] stupid so once it reaches there
the police can't do anything about it
they actual resident so then they have
to actually go to court to prove that
you could do that to any house yeah and
then the and then they even I'll check
the mail and I'll just register at DMV
whatever make sure I pull the mail out
yeah exactly so then there's also this
uh fake lease agreement that they show
that like shows that they're able to
they actually rented the space but the
the uh property agents like that's not
real like we never made one of those who
yeah so who these people are um is
pretty interesting when you look at the
flyers or the kinds of parties they do
it'll be like burning man looking stuff
it'll be like very spiritual kind of
stuff burners they they look like
burners but also I think they're all
like Jewish or like isra Israel like uh
some of the the events are for uh like
in Memorial of the people that died
during the Hamas attack it's like yeah
it's like actual like w like Israeli
American or like Israeli Israeli no just
like Israeli Americans they're tunnels
they look like burning they look burners
yeah wly sh it goes from from freaking
New York it is Beverly Hills yeah
they're just Beverly Hills rich kids
that are like Crystal guys there's a lot
of rra guys there I have never seen that
before it looks pretty different but a
lot of those yoga kids are just Rich
Jewish kids though yeah that makes sense
yeah so the way that the the squatters
are claiming that the former owner
allowed them to live there but the true
owner of the home is really uncertain so
here's what happened there's a guy named
Jeff scapa he's the private mortgage
lender that loaned 3.8 million to to a
company called mdca Properties LLC who
bought the home like a company bought
the home right so uh they defaulted on
the payments which uh Jeff scaa got
clearance to foreclose on the home for
them defaulting but when he tried to
mdca filed bankruptcy which froze the
entire foreclosure process which I think
is like a hack yeah yeah [__] it's like
hey I'm bankrupt so then they have to
like go Circle back and do a whole
different thing crazy crazy so they're
thinking that maybe these are friends of
the people who are being foreclosed on
so there like a long which is why
they're kind of juicing the property
like we're going to we could freeze this
situation now that it's frozen what do
you guys want to do type of thing yeah
it could be cuz they yeah and then those
uh Flyers they'll do like Shabbat
parties and like things like that and
the other events that these same
companies do like the flyer will show
who's throwing the party like it'll have
like names and of companies and and
groups and the other events they do are
uh all over Hollywood and then so they
were offered 25k to leave and they they
said no thanks they're like we make way
more at
booking.com yeah to make matters even
weirder uh when they're looking up who
the last people were that owned this
house before that company bought it it's
a guy named Dr munir Eda who happens to
be the ring leader of a $150 million
insurance scam where they got they got a
attorneys they bribed attorneys into
referring patients who were collecting
workman's comp in order to get surgeries
that they didn't need performed by a
physician's assistant who never went to
med school W so they never performed
anything so let's say that you that you
got hurt at work right and then you're
you have like a a workman's comp program
whatever that guy is going to lie to you
and say oh you need to get this
procedure done and he's going to refer
you to this doctor who doesn't even know
what the hell he's going to do with you
and they just make up some [__]
thing on your leg and now you're
disabled [__] oh wait they actually do
something they actually do it because
they would have a guy who's his
assistant who's not even a doctor do it
they just cut people up they knock you
out you wake up that that doctor never
even touched you some other guy did and
now you're you're living with this
botched surgery you never even
need so they did that to the tuna of
$150 million in Damages from people and
to make it even crazier while this guy
is basically being accused of that this
doctor
um this thing happens where his
girlfriend gets murdered by who they say
is a female assassin he hired to kill
her what the because he had a business
deal with her dad who's in
Pharmaceuticals and it went bad so
apparently he hired someone to kill her
so all this stuff is going down he flees
the country to avoid the charges and
that's how that house first got a banned
I feel like this is the kind of [__]
Jake would have on his channel yeah I
was going to say like maybe maybe
there's a video here cover this yeah
it's yeah go ahead and cover this in
depth dude this sounds interesting Deep
dive on this holy [__] craziest thing so
then I started looking up like who are
some of the people in the uh on the
Flyers and stuff like here's one of the
Flyers it'll it'll say like afterlife
Thursdays what the hell Secret Beverly
Hills mansion location kind of thing
looks like a old school Ray flyer yeah
and then after watch the name of a of a
techno dark techno record label that's
really popular
have you heard of Music cartel record
label no so that's one of the record
labels that it says throws these parties
you go to that page you just see this
like CEO of a dude the pool that he's in
is the pool of that house no way yeah so
I'll show you guys what the what the I
can't believe they could do this so here
that's all the same company huh music
cartel record label and you said the LLC
is MCR too yeah it might be music cartel
is that the like spelled out version of
the uh there's some letters that are not
pres in that but here's the that's the
people like partying at the
house like they're just at the driveway
right there that's them arriving so it's
not like hoodlums it's like actual like
people some money classy looking Party
People yeah what yeah so there's they be
having Bar Mitzvah and [__] so like
Saturday Saturday Saturday is that the
house that thing looks like a castle
that's the house right there holy [__]
so um you can see there that's the party
house and these are the celebs that live
around it so like John leg leg wow yeah
and then here's here's an aerial view of
it damn that house is 4 million 4.3 no
way I think looks like it's $10 million
expensive as [__] uh what if it's like
the small house of the block but it has
a lot of crazy rooms in it it's got like
10 million yeah so here's all the [__]
that gets left behind like the whippits
wow cops and then and then they found
drugs at the back of this Porsche so all
they could do was tow the car that had
them in it they couldn't really do
anything about the squatters when they
found that here's a flyer these are all
the people that throw the Thing music
cartel Gula game over tripus and all
these people are visible on IG
completely they're not hiding wow none
of this stuff is like they're not even
like the these are the tickets that you
can
buy
75 this right here is the actual like
text telling them like parking is free
from 6: p.m. oh my God yeah they just
let him Park all up on a street there's
the front gate damn that's LeBron's
property that's being built two doors
down
whoa that's this is day at a New Year's
party so people are saying that there's
nightly parties and they go like all
like look 10:00 p.m. to 10:00 a.m.
that's the party hours
waa that's that the night shot of it
that's the uh the notice that they got
on the wall about it
yeah so it's just like crazy it's a
crazy thing that nobody can get get them
out and then right next door directly
next door there's a homeowner that's
complaining about it because they have
long-term tenants in that house and they
have to deal with this almost every
night they use one of those as a rental
properties there's a lot of these are I
wonder how much is it like $100,000 a
month could be pissed I'm like I [__]
moved in here to move away from that
[__] yeah so they'll get their like the
the way that the people arrive at these
parties they just drive as far as they
can up the street and then they just
leave their car there and they walk to
the house so the it's like a it's like
gridlock traffic kind of thing oh God
and you're if you're just stuck in your
driveway if you live anywhere near that
that's why I love La so much cuz you're
so tenant friendly you know so if you're
a ten you can do anything yeah you can't
do anything wrong you just screw the
landlord you know Screw the neighborhood
sick dude so [__] sick and then I
guess even before that one Doctor Who
fled the country and abandoned his house
before that d Dash live there no way
love so it's like a house that has some
pretty crazy history and then the re
like I guess when you Summit all up the
reason why it's locked in this situation
is because of that loan that went to
that company that filed back from SE to
like block the foreclosure and now
they're just like who knows how long
until they can get out yeah it's insane
and even when you look at there's lots
of videos of it they hired a private
investigator to collect material on
everybody that's staying there in order
to like flesh out who's there and how
and why this happened and there's aerial
videos of them just like like cleaning
up after parties the place looks
trash yeah and this is happening in a
lot of mansions I heard in La not like
this this is just the craziest yeah I
mean the I've seen it happen in in in
the neighborhood I used to live in but
they would only be able to maybe get
away with like one night but it's crazy
that they know it so well that they got
their license like the address on the
license cuz that's at least the 2 we to
4 week process time yeah
seem like they knew the system and like
set it up from the beginning right and
they're not your common like they're not
uh what is it called they're not like
little hoodlum people like these people
look like they're just very good at
exploiting right at the line yeah wow
they're doing something kind of smart
which sucks why do I pay rent when I
could just squat [__] that's what I'm
telling you but then that's what happens
in the Hills a lot of time there's all
these investment properties that stay
empty for so long like my neighbor how
the freaking girls living there 6 months
they got to catch them doing drugs right
and then they can that's what our
district officer told us but this this
District officer here quoted himself
that there's nothing that they can do at
this point because the the girl that was
faking uh that she lived across the
street from us didn't have an ID she
didn't have an ID to show like that that
had the address but they do that's the
part that changes everything they're
like okay now you have to go to court
wow these little things man in this case
ho having HOA helps don't you police
uphold the law but HOAs have their own
bylaws damn you know what I mean like
the Poli the police aren't going to go
hey your Hedges are above the wall cut
your hedg they just do it's not criminal
I can't do anything but HOA they'll keep
putting notices put and they'll put
fines so in this case if they're having
too too much loud noise whatever the HOA
like kind of like fills in the gap
between what's human and moral and then
what's legal they get to kind of fill in
that Gap right it's crazy too because
some of the neighbors have complained
saying hey here's the breach they're
using the property for something that
it's not allowed to be used for you
can't do this but they're like well
those aren't really the people that are
supposed to be there so you can't charge
them you know what I mean like they're
not if they were the homeowner then you
can get them in trouble for that but
they're not so it's like a great then
what do we do like bro bro nothing
there's nothing you can do isn't that
crazy Jake you got get the bottom of and
the those are the people that actually
live there they're the ones that like
get the noise and all that [__] they're
the ones that are like what the [__] why
is my next door neighbor like this and
they're not homeless they're not even
poor they do events all throughout the
week at different venues they're making
money doing this that's the craziest
part next party what's the let's
go